I mean welcome back Cheryl thank you I
mean literally I'm so happy to see what
interesting it's been a while until them
that we haven't seen each other it's
been a while that anyone you know has
seen you what does it feel like to be
back you know back at work because this
is your first day
this is that day back like it worked
12-hour day today and it feels so
strange should I put maybe around does
it feels really weird like a call is to
get all just a cuddler
and we're on the set of your new makeup
campaign obviously with L'Oreal like
does it feel nice to be all like you
know do not back to makeup back to hair
you know back to cover yet I mean I know
it it uses kind of was always that work
every day you used to do that I think
we're having you know spend time you
know with the baby obviously didn't do
the glam every day know exactly and do
anything so literally for like the first
three months definitely I didn't put a
single thing except moisturizer or oil
on my skin and I've time you don't have
time when you're taking care of every
24/7 it's just not practical either like
what you're gonna do kiss and cuddle and
follow makeup it's a it doesn't make
sense
so today having hair don't make up don't
just feels like a treat only take my
when I first put it on for dinner myself
I looked in the mirror I was like oh my
god I am caked and makeup it's so
strange
it's funny isn't it because you know
sometimes like when when I go on holiday
for like two weeks I won't wear any
makeup and the first day you wear makeup
you kind of you look it's straight yeah
as you kind of believe it but obviously
it's very different thing you know for
me to be away for two weeks up and fold
it's very different for you
do you feel a certain pressure being you
know coming back into the limelight
because obviously you know everyone's
kind of waiting for you to come back are
they all that pressure I feel the
opposite I feel like I could care less
I don't feel any pressure at all and
it's like ever it's like my whole world
has been turned upside down and this is
just a nice little sidestep now it's not
the be-all and end-all of my world
here's that must feel so nice yeah has
you mentioned a little bit about you
know that you weren't wearing much
makeup but it has your skincare routine
changed since becoming a mom and having
less time like I just don't have one I
didn't have one at all whatsoever
honestly I started putting bio oil or
like coconut oil in the bath because
then it cuts out the moisturize and
saying when you get out
so you're moisturized when you get out
your skin feels lovely so I would do
that and I think I'm gonna start buying
that because I have to say I've
interviewed you a few times but your
skin does look absolutely amazing
thank you lowing so maybe you know there
is something to be said for you know
simplifying it's called a contentment
I'm feeling I should try what would you
say what's like the most the biggest
thing you've learned since becoming a
mom maybe about yourself or just to care
less about stupid stuff I just happens
to use like you know it'll consciously
make the evidence of what they won't do
you think I should care less about this
it just happens and looking at you know
career now because obviously what are
you you really thinking about cuz your
schedule it was I mean there was a time
your schedule was insane if I look back
now in saying I can say it but at the
time I was just on the train you know I
was going going going going gone I
didn't really say that it was hectic
that's the beauty of it coming back was
I was like I've got I'm clear minded now
I'm not I don't have a hectic brain I
can say everything clearly again and
it's exciting again and priorities shift
then your schedule is kind of like what
it is
mr. woo
around me and the baby so I do I mean
you know you are a beauty girl and I do
want to talk about your new lipstick
because you know I I made my lipstick I
mean whatever and I went to lab and
mixed it I love that it's it was so much
fun and did you enjoy that I loved it
but as I went there I know what to
expect really I spoke to the guy in
there who told me scientifically tier-4
Tia what happens year to year
what's coming in the future what they do
like how intricate everything is blew me
away and then I went into the lab mixed
colors saw how to make eyeshadow so how
they make mascara so how they do the
brushes differently to make different
effects on your eyelashes it was
fascinating I could have been in there
all day in the different departments and
how like how did you cuz the lip kids
there's three kids and you picked the
shade so there's a peachy kit yet a
grayish kit yeah and then the Bordeaux
or the deep red color how did you I mean
how did you decide on that was the
because at the time when I made it I was
like into that look da flavors stripped
back I and then I told the woman and she
said let's make that there and then
she's like what's your favorite color at
the moment and it was this and that was
your absolute favorite and then we
discussed like whether it should be
matte whether it should be shiny and we
thought Matt was a bit more modern
especially for can I try it yeah cause I
find dr. is quite challenge oh it's a
bit chocolatey they're very very
chocolatey as well do you think your own
because you when I saw you on TV often
you know the shows you're so daring with
makeup like you do you try a different
look
and the thing is when you have like such
a beautiful face thank you everything
looks good no but it's true you have a
face that you just everything looks good
on you has your tastes change slightly
now like because I love how you are
today you're very natural to smoky eye
like do you like kind of has your you
feel more like more into natural makeup
now I think so I think so honestly I
would have been happy to just one
surrounding just me my score are and
meaning of lipstick maybe that's the way
forward I don't know yet I think I'd be
a bit more experimental and say what I
like now and what I don't like because I
feel like everything's changed since
I've been gone everything's changed
and well one thing I have some changes
that you're still is lovely that's for
sure
now one thing that's very important to
you is that one pound from each yeah it
obviously is going to you know your
trust and I know that you're working on
a few things with the trust yeah can we
can you talk about a little bit silly
new may trust now is open in a Center in
New Castle which was the aim from the
beginning because obviously a one I want
to be able to help disadvantaged youth
of they're struggling or struggling with
self-esteem issues or you know like not
being able to get on the next ladder for
work and and all of that stuff in this
there's so many benefits to the center
and it's gonna be opening later in this
year so that's super exciting to me like
that's a project I've had going for yes
for five years now I've been working up
to that it's not easy and Laurie has
always been amazing super supportive we
didn't lipsticks in the past where we've
given money and stuff like that so this
time one pound of each lip cake goes to
her a lot I have to say yeah it's
important to me so and then
now okay Liam said that the Kardashians
are often on on TV at home yeah
whose future look do you like best out
of the production and with the girls
yeah well you like to be honest it's on
sometimes but it was being watching it
because I'm taking care of a baby I
don't know what's going down there but
yeah I think they're all beautiful in
their own way don't you think they've
all got like their own something going
on no I agree and also they're a
beautiful family that's that's the thing
and finally I'm born on the 22nd of
March and I just wanna tell you that us
early Aries babies the best can you tell
me treats cuz I don't really know any
Aries and I mean obviously boys and
girls on there he's slightly different
but definitely like determined by I
would say I mean obviously I'm gonna
describe myself and go on in the best
possible way but I think definitely like
big heart but determined so I don't know
if you've really noticed quite a
stubborn kind of like strength like kind
of steadfast you know but no that was
just something you know listened to you
know that but I'd like to get in contact
if any - no sir yes definitely you know
where I am
but thank you so much thank you we're
talking to us today thank you very much
[Music]